bonjour je m'appelle anneiro j'habite à
Saint-Denis je recherche un contrat de
professionnalisation en pâtisserie je
suis passionnée depuis petite par la
pâtisserie je peux me déplacer sur
saint-denier Sainte-Marie je viens
d'obtenir récemment un bac STMG en
spécialité
mercatique je peux tenir une caisse et
avoir une bonne relation clientèle j'ai
effectué plusieurs stages en magasin en
tant que vendeuse
dont tendance chaussur qui se situe à
Saint-Denis au R Marchal lecla j'ai un
très bon savoir-faire avec le client je
suis enthousiaste ponctuel et motivé je
suis impassant de travailler et de faire
de ma passion un métier